.
HE POSTED IT TO FACEBOOK DURING
THE STANDOFF.
HE NOW FACES BANK ROBBERY AND
ALSO KIDNAPPING CHARGES.
>>> GOVERNMENT TROOPS IN
AFGHANISTAN ARE LOSING GROUND TO
THE TALIBAN.
THE INSURGENTS ARE STEPPING UP
PRESSURE ON THE AFGHAN ARMY AS
AMERICAN FORCES WITHDRAW.
THE U.S. MILITARY'S TOP GENERAL
SAID YESTERDAY, QUOTE, WE HAVE
TO SEE HOW THIS PLAYS OUT.
CHARLIE D'AGATA'S IN KABUL,
AFGHANISTAN'S CAPITAL.
HOW IS IT PLAYING OUT SO FAR?
>> Reporter: WELL, ANTHONY, IT'S
NOT PLAYING OUT VERY WELL.
IT'S LESS THAN A WEEK SINCE THE
OFFICIAL U.S. DRAWDOWN GOT UNDER
WAY, AND THE TALIBAN IS ON THE
MARCH, CAPTURING EVEN MORE
TERRITORY NORTH OF KABUL
OVERNIGHT.
AFGHAN FORCES FELL BACK TO SAFER
FIGHTING POSITIONS IN WHAT THE
CALLED A TACTICAL RETREAT.
TO THE TALIBAN, SEEN HERE WITH A
CAPTURED ARMY HUMVEE, IT'S
ANOTHER VICTORY.
U.S. AIR STRIKES HAVE BEEN
CALLED IN TO HELP STRUGGLING
AFGHAN TROOPS WITH THE TAPGZ ON
THE WAR PATH -- KALAMTALIBAN ON
WAR PATH.
THEY'RE BARELY NEGOTIATED IN
NINE MONTHS.
>> WORST CASE SCENARIO WILL BE A
COMPLETE, ALL-OUT WAR.
>> Reporter: THE GRIM PROSPECT
OF A CIVIL WAR IS SOMETHING THAT
AHMAD MASSOUD AND FOLLOWERS ARE
PREPARING FOR.
>> I FIGHT FOR IT.
>> Reporter: HIS FATHER GAVE HIS
LIFE FOR IT, AHMED SHAH MASSOUD
THE TALIBAN IN THE 1990s.
HE WAS ASSASSINATED JUST TWO
DAYS BEFORE 9/11.
THE TALIBAN KNEW THE U.S. WOULD
RETALIATE WITH EVERYTHING AT ITS
DISPOSAL.
MASSOUD WOULD BE TOO DANGEROUS
AN ALLY.
SHOULD THE AFGHAN MILITARY
COLLAPSE, HIS SON SAYS HE AND
OTHERS STAND READY TO TAKE UP
ARMS IN WHAT SOME ARE ALREADY
CALLING RESISTANCE 2.0.
IT SOUND LIKE YOU'REMILITANCY.
>> IT WILL NOT -- IT WILL BE
PEOPLE READY TO FIGHT.
IT WILL BE AN ORGANIZED
RESISTANCE AGAINST THE TALIBAN.
>> Reporter: IF IT SHOULD COME
TO THAT.
>> IF IT COME TO THAT.
>> Reporter: LIKE MOST PEOPLE IN
AFGHANISTAN, HE'S HOPING IT DOES
NOT COME TO THAT.
HE WOULD RATHER THE FRAGMENTED
GOVERNMENT UNIFY AND FIND SOME
SORT OF PEACEFUL SOLUTION.
>> WE WERE READY TO FORGIVE THE
TALIBAN AND TO MOVE ON.
>> Reporter: FORGIVE THE
TALIBAN?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
AND THEY KILLED MY FATHER, AL
QAEDA KILLED MY FATHER.
>> Reporter: YOU'RE WILLING TO
FORGIVE, BUT YOU'RE ALSO READY
TO FIGHT.
>> YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> Reporter: MASSOUD RETURNED TO
AFGHANISTAN AFTER GRADUATING
FROM COLLEGE IN THE UK AROUND
FIVE YEARS AGO.
HE SAID HE MADE A VOW TO HIS
FATHER TO CAR